I've just landed in the capsule Bangkok
and I'm straight off the plane and ready
for my first taste of Thailand
food everywhere
every inch of these patients
food after food after food after food
tires Britain's fastest growing cruising
and I can't wait to get to grips with it
now I know how to make a pad thai but
that's about the extent of my Thai
cuisine repertoire there's better than
just pad thai here I've got my work cut
out just one week to master authentic
Thai food so I've asked one of
Thailand's top chefs to help me on my
way now there's one do unique individual
cool chef but dang paradis guys clocked
at more primetime hours than me
this guy's gonna set me on the right
track I can't wait to get started I've
agreed to meet celebrity chef Matt dang
for dinner first are frying and to
market between squids come fast oh look
at a place not at a fancy restaurant he
asked me to meet him at his favorite
street food stall in Bangkok to educate
me in authentic Thai cooking dance no
he's given me a map but it's a foreign
language to me
but I know a star when I see one spot
your mile away how are you gonna see you
meet you how are you very much do you
think so excited be here
this place is basically amazing amazing
and it's this is one of my favorite star
hello ivy
this is mr. whiskers mr. whiskers right
and the most populous would be pet toy
no no oh Jesus you're crazy okay why not
that's really boring is this yeah
because every Westerner says Oh Thai
food pad thai okay bull why don't you
try something that we consider that like
the Thai hamburger a one plate dish that
we always eat okay Kapow Kapow
take me through please cooking the Thai
wing looks simple but there are strict
principles I need to master give me the
secret behind good Thai cuisine it's a
balance of taste nice saltiness and
sound but you cannot cook Thai food
without a pale-faced saltiness sweetness
soundness in a paste is the bedrock of
Thai food with different ingredients
used to deliver the essential flavours
he just put in fish style fish sauce and
then the sauce was always the sauce much
sweetness in it and what is that that's
the the business to hold the holy basil
I mean it smells incredible
[Music]
there you go thank you can I do this
break that you just stuck yeah a crispy
fried on top on top of my delicious puck
the pile why you find an egg on top of
this amazing food Wow I know but this is
how we eat it it combines all the
flavors who has delicious it works my
first taste of authentic Thai food has
impressed me it's bursting with flavor
mcdhh an has got more to show me
[Music]
you know I have a television show I
heard yeah it's on what once a year give
me a break
we do every week
still 52 weeks yeah so you have more
experience for me on television right
you see everybody in Thailand knows
where would you consider coming on my
show well on your show live so you can
mince me I am NOT gonna miss you we got
a telephone and talk to each other what
we're going to do I could be wrong
hey okay you're on one big question yes
I'm a real chef
are you a TV chef or real chefs any real
chef because everyone just thought well
we'll find out next week okay now it's
too much I thought he was a bit of a
joke to begin with but he's actually
quite serious and he knows his [ __ ] and
I'm a Thai cooking novice with just one
week to reach mukbang standards or face
a very public humiliation okay out turn
left
taxi